how much do you pay attention to
approval ratings
well not anymore
i'm joking
they're trying to prop up this old man
because they got nothing nothing so here
is jimmy fallon praising joe biden for
no reason anyone can discern a lot of
republicans and democrats you should get
really unwell together for example one
of the reasons i'm a little bit late
coming on is it because not coming on
but to do the taping here is because i
did bob dole's eulogy today we gave you
standing ovation because i go here he is
he's bringing class back
he's a classy guy and you're bringing
class back to the office and i thought
it was kind of amazing that he did that
well it's it's so much class being
brought back to the office
guess what the american people are not
falling for this